This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. You have the desire to help a real difference? The College, LaCite, you offer the program Dependance and Scenti Mental. Acquare the competences
这是一个I-Heart播客。保证真实。您是否有意愿去做出真正的改变？LaCite学院为您提供“依赖与情感”课程。获取相关能力
essential to accompany and support the people confronted to the challenges. Construise a career enrichicent to service of the community francophone
对于陪伴和支持那些面临挑战的人们至关重要。构建一份丰富的职业生涯，服务于法语社区
of all the country. Don't know the Swin'Alice in French, it's possible with the CIT. Visit CollageLac.C.
遍布全国。不知道法语的Swin'Alice？通过CIT是有可能的。请访问CollageLac.C。
D.M.C. a initiative of the chief of the Consortium National of Formation in Health, supported by Santa Canada. There was no anything inside those eyes. They turned black. It scared the hell out of me. Evil, wake up.
D.M.C. 是国家健康培训联盟负责人发起的一项倡议，由加拿大卫生部支持。那些眼睛里什么都没有。它们变成了黑色。这把我吓坏了。邪恶，醒醒。
I'm the woman that saw the murder take place by Crevette and DePippo. Anthony DePippo showed no signs of remorse, appearing unfazed after being sentenced to the maximum. I said, I'm not guilty. I'll take it to the grief. Listen to the devil's quarry in the Bone Valley feed on the IHeart Radio app. Apple Podcasts or wherever you get your podcasts. Joy is essential and it's also elusive.
我就是那个目睹了Crevette和DePippo谋杀案的女人。安东尼·德皮波（Anthony DePippo）在被判处最高刑罚后表现得毫无悔意，看起来泰然自若。我说，我没有罪。我会把这件事带进坟墓。请在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《骨谷》（Bone Valley）中的《魔鬼采石场》（Devil's Quarry）。快乐是必不可少的，但它也难以捉摸。
But now, there's a new and exciting way to start your journey toward a more joyful existence. Joy 101. It's a new podcast hosted by me, Hoda Kotby. If you're craving inspiration to maximize your joy, tune into these candid, uplifting and moving on-air chats. Open your free IHeart radio app. Search Joy 101 and listen now. Joy 101 with Hoda Kotbe is presented by CVS.
但现在，有一种新的、令人兴奋的方式可以开启您的旅程，迈向更快乐的生活。《快乐101》（Joy 101）。这是一个由我，霍达·科特比（Hoda Kotby）主持的新播客。如果您渴望获得灵感来最大化您的快乐，请收听这些坦诚、振奋人心且感人的广播聊天。打开您免费的IHeart Radio应用程序。搜索“Joy 101”并立即收听。由CVS赞助的《快乐101》与霍达·科特比。
Everyone sees me as a football player, but before anything else, I'm human. Every single day I'm still learning how to live with problems, mistakes, relationships, emotions ever since I was born. This isn't a normal podcast. Everything here is spontaneous, real and genuine, just honest conversations about what it means to be alive.
每个人都视我为足球运动员，但首先，我是一个人。从出生起，我每天都在学习如何处理问题、错误、人际关系和情绪。这不是一个普通的播客。这里的一切都是自发的、真实的、真诚的，只是关于作为一个人意味着什么的诚实对话。
I'm Javier El Chicharito Hernandez and listen to Learning to Be Human on IHard Radio, Apple Podcasts, or whatever you get your podcast. Here's something that should not be as complicated as it is, getting a racist statue removed. And here's something that should be a whole lot easier than it is, getting a new one put up in its place. I'm Akela Hughes, and Rebel Spirit, season two, is about both of those things. As I was watching these statues come down, I was thinking about what it meant that I grew up in a majority black city in which there were more homages to enslavers than there were to enslave people. Listen to Rebel Spirit Season 2 on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
我是哈维尔·“小豌豆”·埃尔南德斯（Javier El Chicharito Hernandez），请在IHeart Radio、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《学习做人》（Learning to Be Human）。这里有一件事本不该如此复杂，那就是移除种族主义雕像。而这里有一件事本该比现在容易得多，那就是在原处竖立一座新的雕像。我是阿凯拉·休斯（Akela Hughes），《反叛精神》（Rebel Spirit）第二季就是关于这两件事的。当我在观看这些雕像被拆除时，我在思考，我在一个黑人占多数的城市长大，那里对奴隶主的致敬比对被奴役者的致敬还要多，这意味着什么。请在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《反叛精神》第二季。
Hello everybody. I'm Gemma Spike and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through the biggest changes, moments and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. It is so great to have you here.
大家好。我是杰玛·斯派克（Gemma Spike），欢迎回到《20多岁的心理学》（The Psychology of Your 20s），这是一个我们探讨20多岁时最大的变化、时刻和转变，以及它们对我们心理意味着什么的播客。大家好。欢迎回到节目。欢迎回到播客。很高兴有你们在这里。
I literally landed in London back from Australia like five hours ago and the jet lag is really setting in right now. So bear with me. But I feel like this episode can't wait. I feel like this is the most pressing feeling of our generation of our time that needs to be discussed before like the next world disaster hits in probably the next few days. And the topic for today, that is our anxiety about the future. future, our anxiety about the future of the world, the future of our lives, and how to manage it.
我刚从澳大利亚回到伦敦，大概是五个小时前，时差反应现在真的开始了。所以请多包涵。但我感觉这一集不能等。我觉得这是我们这一代人、我们这个时代最紧迫的感觉，需要在下一次世界灾难在未来几天内发生之前进行讨论。今天的主题是：我们对未来的焦虑。未来，我们对世界未来的焦虑，对我们生活未来的焦虑，以及如何管理它。
I don't think that I've had a conversation, a single conversation in the past six months that hasn't included some mention of an ever-present existential threat kind of lingering over our lives. That combined with all of our personal worries and anxieties about the future as 20-somethings, meant that it kind of felt like the right time to do an episode on catastrophizing and how to stay grounded right now when our thoughts are probably going a thousand miles a minute. I'm a major catastropher. And if you are like me, the thought spirals, the negativity spirals are probably nonstop at the moment. And it's annoying. It's annoying. It's frustrating. It leaves little room to really think about anything else. It leaves little room to get stuff done, little room to enjoy the present,
我不认为我在过去六个月里进行过任何一次没有提到某种挥之不去的、无处不在的生存威胁的对话。这与我们作为20多岁年轻人对未来的所有个人担忧和焦虑结合在一起，意味着现在似乎是做一期关于灾难化思维以及当我们的思绪可能每分钟飞驰千里时如何保持冷静的合适时机。我是一个严重的灾难化者。如果你像我一样，思维螺旋、负面螺旋此刻可能正在不停地旋转。这很烦人。这很烦人。这令人沮丧。它几乎没有空间去真正思考其他任何事情。它几乎没有空间去完成事情，几乎没有空间去享受当下，
for what it is. So today I want to give an explanation as to what is happening in your brain as these spirals are taking place. Why your anxiety about the future is probably so dominant right now. B, the effect that that's having on us so you can have a little bit of grace if you are finding it harder to focus, finding it harder to be present. And C, most importantly, the five things that you can do to re-center. I don't want to want to. to say, I don't want to say relax, but re-center, renew, re-establish some good routines and some good habits to let you kind of concentrate on what you can control, what you can do, the good that you can bring to the world, and I don't want to say be less focused, but not let the negative
享受它本来的样子。所以今天我想解释一下当这些螺旋发生时你的大脑里正在发生什么。为什么你对未来的焦虑现在可能如此占主导地位。B，这对我们产生的影响，这样如果你发现自己更难集中注意力，更难活在当下时，你可以对自己宽容一点。C，最重要的是，你可以做的五件事来重新找回重心。我不想说放松，而是重新找回重心、更新、重建一些良好的日常习惯，让你能够专注于你能控制的事情，你能做的事情，你能带给世界的美好，我不想说减少关注，而是不要让负面
thoughts and the negative perspective be the primary ones. So without further ado, let's get into how to manage your anxiety about the future right now. So if you're in your 20s, I think most of you are, I would say the majority of us are, who are listening to this podcast. I think the world is kind of serving us two types of anxieties about the future. The first one is the broader, high-level anxiety about the state that the world is in, which kind of just like dominates everything. You know, I could go into a long list.
思想和负面视角成为主要的想法。所以事不宜迟，让我们进入如何管理你现在对未来的焦虑。所以如果你20多岁，我想你们大多数人都是，我会说我们大多数听这个播客的人都是。我认为世界正在向我们提供两种对未来的焦虑。第一种是关于世界现状的更广泛、高层面的焦虑，它几乎主导了一切。你知道，我可以列出一长串清单。
I could talk about AI, I could talk about war, I could talk about, I don't know, fuel crisis. There's just too many things to list, right? And that, it's a lot. That is really why we are so impacted by it. Like there's this sense of like, what do I worry about first? That is the first level of like mass uncertainty and mass anxiety that we're up against. Like it just feels like the world is going through more changes now than it. ever has before. Whether that is true or not, it definitely is the pressing and dominant feeling.
我可以谈论人工智能，我可以谈论战争，我可以谈论，我不知道，燃料危机。有太多的事情要列举了，对吧？而且，这很多。这确实是我们受其影响如此之深的原因。就像有一种“我该先担心什么”的感觉。这是我们面临的第一层大规模不确定性和大规模焦虑。就像世界现在经历的变化比以往任何时候都多。无论这是不是真的，这绝对是紧迫和主导的感觉。
The second type of anxiety that a lot of us are experiencing right now is just our anxiety about our own personal circumstances. Like, despite what's going on in the world, it's not selfish to still care about what we're up against. You know, for those of us just starting out in adult life, that's basically anyone under the age of 35 as far as I see it. Like, we are particularly faced with the sense of uncertainty about things that are more personal to us, about our career, the state of our love lives, our friendships, our financial situation. Our 20s are defined by a lack of definition, which is deeply exciting because everything is possible and also deeply stressful
我们许多人现在正在经历的第二种焦虑只是我们对自己个人情况的焦虑。就像，尽管世界上发生了什么，关心我们自己面临的问题并不自私。你知道，对于我们这些刚开始成年生活的人来说，据我所知，基本上是任何35岁以下的人。就像，我们特别面临着对我们个人事情的不确定感，关于我们的职业，我们的爱情生活状态，我们的友谊，我们的财务状况。我们的20多岁是由缺乏定义所定义的，这非常令人兴奋，因为一切皆有可能，但也非常令人压力巨大，
because we are literally staring at a blank slate and there's a lot of responsibility that comes with the beginning of something. The very fact that we are at the beginning of our adult lives is unsettling, but also it means that we're less established. such that those two levels of anxiety we're talking about combine forces, right? Yes, we have that anxiety about our personal lives and what we want from our future, but it is more destabilized. We are more destabilized by what is going on in the world.
因为我们实际上是在盯着一张白纸，而开始某件事伴随着很大的责任。我们正处于成年生活的开端这一事实令人不安，但也意味着我们还不够稳固。以至于我们正在谈论的那两层焦虑结合在一起了，对吧？是的，我们对个人生活和我们对未来的期望有那种焦虑，但它更加不稳定。我们被世界上正在发生的事情搞得更加不稳定。
We are more sensitive to what is changing because we probably don't have the savings of people who are older than us. We don't have the experiences of people who are older than us. We don't have the skill set that protects against some of the economic and, like, sociopolitical and workplace uncertainties. So basically, all that's just to validate what you're probably experiencing right now, which is a lot of fear. And to say it goes without saying that our generation, our age group,
我们对正在发生的变化更加敏感，因为我们可能没有比我们年长的人那样的积蓄。我们没有比我们年长的人那样的经验。我们没有能够抵御某些经济、社会政治和工作场所不确定性的技能组合。所以基本上，所有这些只是为了验证你现在可能正在经历的事情，那就是大量的恐惧。并且可以说，我们这一代人、我们这个年龄段，
is more primed to be anxious than most. And often that anxiety and that rumination is actually the only sense of control that we have. What I think a lot of us need to be more, I don't know, more kind to ourselves about it is that our anxiety is the coping mechanism right now. You may have heard a specific word for this. It's called anticipatory anxiety. And it's essentially when we borrow stress, suffering, fear from the future by attempting to problem solve a hypothetical situation that hasn't happened yet in the present. basically a complicated way of saying we think that we can avoid future anxiety by making it a today problem. The issue is that that's entirely irrational. No level of thinking about something
比大多数人更容易感到焦虑。而且通常那种焦虑和反刍实际上是我们拥有的唯一控制感。我认为我们许多人需要对自己更……我不知道，更友善一点的是，我们的焦虑现在是一种应对机制。你可能听说过这个特定的词。它被称为预期性焦虑。它本质上是我们通过试图解决一个在当下尚未发生的假设情况，从未来借用压力、痛苦和恐惧。基本上这是一种复杂的方式，说我们认为我们可以通过把它变成一个今天的问题来避免未来的焦虑。问题在于这是完全不理性的。没有任何程度的思考某件事
can change what is going to happen. But that doesn't matter. Like that's the reason it is a form of anxiety because it is irrational. Let me break down for you why. Why despite this irrationality our brain likes to pursue this path of future fear, even when it doesn't necessarily make sense or doesn't necessarily help us. Like, why do we find ourselves worrying so continuously about things that we cannot change when that feels so impractical? There are a few reasons. Reason number one is just this illusion of certainty.
可以改变将要发生的事情。但这并不重要。就像这就是它是一种焦虑形式的原因，因为它是不理性的。让我为你分析一下为什么。为什么尽管这种不理性，我们的大脑还是喜欢追求这种未来恐惧的道路，即使它并不一定有意义或并不一定能帮助我们。就像，为什么我们发现自己如此持续地担心那些我们无法改变的事情，而这感觉如此不切实际？有几个原因。第一个原因是这种确定性的错觉。
Essentially, constantly thinking about all the potential, horrible ways or the horrible futures we could face, at least it gives our mind something to do. at least it gives our mind a sense that we're doing something productive about our fear because we are being cognitively mentally preventative. As is the case with all overthinking. We don't actually fear the situation. We fear that we won't be able to cope with the situation. And so to remove that primary fear in advance, we run through all of these scenarios because
本质上，不断思考所有潜在的、可怕的方式或我们可能面临的可怕未来，至少给了我们的大脑一些事情做。至少它给了我们的大脑一种感觉，即我们正在对我们的恐惧做一些富有成效的事情，因为我们在认知上、心理上是预防性的。正如所有过度思考的情况一样。我们实际上并不害怕这种情况。我们害怕的是我们将无法应对这种情况。因此，为了提前消除那种主要的恐惧，我们经历了所有这些场景，因为
it gives us a sense that we are practicing. what we would do if we were in that scenario mentally. Like, we're rehearsing things going wrong so that we're going to be better at handling it when they obviously do go wrong. The problem is we're just thinking about the worst case scenario. We're not thinking about how we would survive it. We're not actually doing any of the coping when we're imagining the world falling apart. You know the quote, I don't know what it is, like the thing we fear the most is fear itself.
它给了我们一种感觉，即我们在心理上练习如果我们处于那种场景中会做什么。就像，我们在排练事情出错，这样当它们显然出错时，我们会更擅长处理。问题是我们只是在思考最坏的情况。我们没有在思考我们将如何生存。当我们想象世界崩溃时，我们实际上并没有做任何应对。你知道那句名言，我不知道是什么，就像我们最害怕的是恐惧本身。
I always thought that this is what I was talking about. Our fear of uncertainty is the ultimate fear because it's just revealing all the ways that we are weak all at once. You know, at our core, we hate uncertainty. Humans hate uncertainty. Whether it's an exam result, whether it's waiting for a text back, wanting to know if you ever find love, if you ever find your place, wanting to know what's going to happen in the world, the blank space of head of us, we don't like it.
我一直认为这就是我在谈论的。我们对不确定性的恐惧是终极恐惧，因为它只是揭示了我们所有软弱的方式。你知道，在我们的核心，我们讨厌不确定性。人类讨厌不确定性。无论是考试结果，还是等待回复短信，想知道你是否会找到爱，是否会找到你的位置，想知道世界上会发生什么，我们面前的空白空间，我们不喜欢它。
because ambiguity is where anxiety can be most imaginative and creative because it's where they're the least constraints because there's nothing we can predict. Studies have provided so much evidence from this. Like I feel like you guys just know this from feeling it. But to give you some of the research, there was a 2011 study, for example, that tested 78 participants on their fear of uncertainty. And these participants were divided into three groups. Basically, the experience, The researchers said, we're going to show you some pictures. For one group, they said, we're going to show you some pictures of something neutral, like vegetables, whatever. The second group, they said, we're going to show you pictures of something that's really, really terrifying.
因为模糊性是焦虑最能发挥想象力和创造力的地方，因为它是限制最少的地方，因为没有什么我们可以预测。研究提供了很多证据。就像我觉得你们只是从感觉中知道这一点。但为了提供一些研究，例如，2011年的一项研究测试了78名参与者对不确定性的恐惧。这些参与者被分为三组。基本上，实验者说，我们要给你们看一些图片。对于一组，他们说，我们要给你们看一些中性的东西，比如蔬菜，什么的。第二组，他们说，我们要给你们看一些非常、非常可怕的东西。
We're going to show you pictures of violence, of snakes, of terrible things. In the third category, they didn't tell them what the picture would be. They said, there may be some pictures of some mutual things, there may be some pictures of some scary things. this group had the highest level of anxiety of any of the other groups. Even the group that knew 100% of the time, they were going to see the scary image. You would imagine that that group would be the most fearful, right? Because there was a 100% chance they were going to see something they didn't want to see. But what this study really revealed was that, again, it's not the fear.
我们要给你们看暴力、蛇、可怕东西的图片。在第三类中，他们没有告诉他们图片会是什么。他们说，可能有一些中性东西的图片，可能有一些可怕东西的图片。这一组的焦虑水平是所有其他组中最高的。即使是那组100%知道他们会看到可怕图像的人。你会想象那组人会是最害怕的，对吧？因为他们有100%的机会看到他们不想看到的东西。但这项研究真正揭示的是，同样，这不是恐惧。
It's the uncertainty about whether what's going to happen will be good or bad. It's that 50-50 chance that means that you're not. never feel fully prepared. Another interesting finding from this same study in that round where there was a 50-50 chance, you know, are you going to see the positive or neutral image or are you going to see the negative image? The participants always expected the negative. Every single round, their body was showing signs that they were anticipating the worst-case scenario, even though the outcome could just have easily have been neutral. We see this outside in experimental setting all the time.
是对将要发生的事情是好是坏的不确定性。正是那50-50的机会意味着你永远不会感到完全准备好。同一项研究在有50-50机会的那一轮中还有另一个有趣的发现，你知道，你是会看到积极或中性的图像，还是会看到消极的图像？参与者总是预期消极的结果。每一轮，他们的身体都在显示他们正在预期最坏情况的迹象，尽管结果同样可能是中性的。我们在实验环境之外一直看到这种情况。
We never overthink that things could go well. Like when was last time you expected not just a good outcome but like a neutral outcome? Our mind never goes down that path. It always chooses the worst case scenario. So of course it's going to be all-consuming. It's skewed towards everything terrible. Like again, your brain doesn't have to prepare for the best-case scenario because it's the best. And so anytime you're thinking about the future, of course, I would say the majority of the time,
我们从不过度思考事情会进展顺利。就像你上次期待的不仅仅是一个好的结果，而是一个中性的结果是什么时候？我们的大脑从不走那条路。它总是选择最坏的情况。所以当然它会是全神贯注的。它倾向于所有可怕的事情。就像再说一遍，你的大脑不需要为最好的情况做准备，因为那是最好的。所以任何时候你在思考未来，当然，我会说大多数时候，
you're going to be thinking about the ways that it's not going to go well and all the terrible hypotheticals. It's just skewing your perception. And it's why when we actually arrive at the situations that we fear, it's often not all that bad. Like you kind of just breathe a sigh of relief at times. Maybe that's one of the, I don't want to say the benefits. I don't want to go that far but one of the weird side effects is that when we get to situations that we feared so often often there is a level of relief there that like it's not as bad as we thought it was going to be like does that make sense there's been so many other studies that have you know repeated this finding again and again and again we anticipate the worst case scenario but what they also show
你都会在思考事情不会进展顺利的方式和所有可怕的假设。它只是扭曲了你的感知。这就是为什么当我们真正到达我们害怕的情况时，通常并没有那么糟糕。就像你有时会松一口气。也许这是，我不想说好处。我不想走那么远，但奇怪的副作用之一是，当我们到达我们如此害怕的情况时，通常会有一种解脱感，就像它没有我们想象的那么糟糕。这有意义吗？已经有这么多其他研究重复了这个发现，一次又一次。我们预期最坏的情况，但它们也显示
is that when we anticipate the worst case scenario being in a state of uncertainty makes our executive functioning worse. And this is one of those weird human evolutionary biology ironies. The evolutionary explanation would say worrying about the future allows us to anticipate things that we need to survive, allows us to practice or rehearse how we're going to cope. But equally, the science tells us that being in that state of uncertainty and always imagining the worst-case scenario actually
当我们预期最坏的情况时，处于不确定状态会使我们的执行功能变差。这是人类进化生物学中奇怪的讽刺之一。进化解释会说，担心未来使我们能够预见我们需要生存的东西，使我们能够练习或排练我们将如何应对。但同样，科学告诉我们，处于那种不确定状态并总是想象最坏的情况实际上
harms our body's biological ability to cope. So some evidence of this, there are studies that suggest that being in a state of uncertainty makes our executive functioning worse, makes our level of coping worse, makes our frontal lobe's ability to execute rational thought worse, makes our, even our body less physically prepared. There was a study from 2020 that showed this. they got a bunch of participants and they said to them, you're going to do a speech?
损害了我们身体的生物学应对能力。所以一些证据，有一些研究表明，处于不确定状态会使我们的执行功能变差，使我们的应对水平变差，使我们额叶执行理性思维的能力变差，甚至使我们的身体在生理上准备不足。2020年的一项研究显示了这一点。他们找了一群参与者，对他们说，你要做一个演讲？
We're either going to tell you what you have to do the speech on or when not. Actually, I think it was like they might have to do a speech, they might not. They did know the topic. But those who were uncertain about whether they were going to have to do that, they were then presented with this other task at the same time where they had to compete, like I think they had to do some computer task or whatever. And that group did so poorly on that task. They made incorrect judgment errors.
我们要么告诉你必须做什么演讲，要么不告诉。实际上，我想是他们可能必须做一个演讲，也可能不需要。他们确实知道主题。但那些不确定是否必须做演讲的人，同时被要求完成另一项任务，他们必须竞争，我想他们必须做一些电脑任务什么的。而那一组在那个任务上表现得非常差。他们做出了错误的判断。
They couldn't operate properly. They made poor decisions. All because the uncertainty of this other situation they were in was taking away their cognitive resources without them knowing it. So this is so important to understand. if you are really like staring down the barrel of some like crazy anxiety about your future right now, you're like a precipice of like some major life changes. If you are feeling like you are not doing well in other areas of your life because of that,
他们无法正常操作。他们做出了糟糕的决定。所有这些都是因为他们所处的另一种情况的不确定性在他们不知情的情况下夺走了他们的认知资源。所以理解这一点非常重要。如果你现在真的盯着某种关于你未来的疯狂焦虑，你就像处于某种重大生活变化的悬崖边上。如果你觉得因为那个原因你在生活的其他方面做得不好，
the science is telling me and is telling you that that is a very likely explanation. Essentially don't be so hard on yourself. Being in the state of uncertainty about where your career is going to go, where you're going to live, how your relationships are going to turn out. That is like having 20 tabs open in the background, churning through all your cognitive resources, churning through like your battery power whilst you're just trying to live your life. So that is the general human explanation, right? Our brain doesn't like uncertainty. Our brain tries to cope with uncertainty by overthinking. That overthinking actually makes it harder.
科学正在告诉我，也正在告诉你，这是一个非常可能的解释。本质上，不要对自己太苛刻。处于对你的职业将走向何方、你将住在哪里、你的关系将如何发展的不确定状态。这就像在后台打开了20个标签，在你试图过生活的同时，消耗着你所有的认知资源，消耗着你的电池电量。所以这就是一般的人类解释，对吧？我们的大脑不喜欢不确定性。我们的大脑试图通过过度思考来应对不确定性。那种过度思考实际上使它变得更难。
But for some people, catastrophizing has much deeper roots. Like it's not just, an instinctual thing, it's more entrenched. It's learned from an unpredictable childhood environment, an unpredictable relationship. Others might catastrophize because of trauma. I think it's important to, again, have grace, that there are situations that you may have been through that are going to put you in this state of like catastrophizing more than other people, often because it's not just about regaining control in a practicing manner, but not wanting to be blinds. sided. If in the past, like, somebody has come out and hurt you and you did not anticipate it, life has changed underneath and in front of you rapidly. You are more likely to have anxiety about
但对于一些人来说，灾难化思维有更深层的根源。就像它不仅仅是一种本能的东西，它更根深蒂固。它是从不可预测的童年环境、不可预测的关系中学习到的。其他人可能会因为创伤而灾难化。我认为重要的是，再次强调，要宽容，有些情况你可能经历过，会让你比其他人更容易处于这种灾难化的状态，通常是因为这不仅仅是关于以练习的方式重新获得控制，而是不想被突袭。如果过去有人出来伤害了你，而你没有预料到，生活在你脚下和面前迅速改变了。你更有可能对
the future because you have past experiences that are showing you and have taught you more than other people how quickly things can change. There's also this fascinating psychology and this fascinating research that says your level of anxiety about the future may also be a personality trait. There's this personality trait called tolerance for uncertainty. And essentially what this research found was that there are some people who, for whom ambiguity, not knowing what's going on in life, not knowing what the future is going to be, it is so much more painful than the average person. and it's not just because they're more sensitive, it's not just because they, I don't know,
未来感到焦虑，因为你有过去的经验，这些经验向你展示并教会了你比其他人更快的事情可以改变。还有这种迷人的心理学和迷人的研究，说你对未来的焦虑水平也可能是一种人格特质。有一种人格特质叫做“不确定性容忍度”。本质上，这项研究发现，有些人对于模糊性、不知道生活中发生了什么、不知道未来会怎样，比普通人痛苦得多。这不仅仅是因为他们更敏感，不仅仅是因为他们，我不知道，
more politically engaged or they're more anxious. Again, it's because of how their personality has been set up, what their temperament is. They have this compulsive drive to want predictability, to want closure. It's part of how they are. It's part of who they are. This trait was first identified in the 1990s by researchers at this Canadian university,
更关心政治，或者他们更焦虑。同样，这是因为他们的人格是如何设置的，他们的气质是什么。他们有一种强迫性的驱动力，想要可预测性，想要终结。这是他们的一部分。这是他们是谁的一部分。这种特质最早是在1990年代由加拿大这所大学的研究人员确定的，
and they found that people with this trait often needed more reassurance about things being okay. They had a tendency towards excessive information seeking, so spending a lot of time researching, looking at the news, seeing what other people were doing. And again, it all came back to this fundamental need within these people for control and for answers. The problem for us, though, and the problem especially for people who are high in his personality trait, is that no one can give you those answers, not about how the world is going turn out, not about how your life is going to turn out. The issue is that people with this trait can't stop trying though. And I think that's its own level of curse that goes beyond just the
他们发现具有这种特质的人通常需要更多关于事情会好起来的保证。他们倾向于过度寻求信息，所以花很多时间研究、看新闻、看别人在做什么。同样，这一切都归结为这些人内心对控制和答案的基本需求。然而，对我们来说，特别是对那些这种人格特质很高的人来说，问题在于没有人能给你那些答案，无论是关于世界将如何发展，还是关于你的生活将如何发展。问题是具有这种特质的人却无法停止尝试。我认为这本身就是一种诅咒，超越了仅仅是
natural human desire for certainty. So we've talked about why this is. We've talked about the psychological impact of this on your rationality, on your executive functioning, on your mood, on your physical preparedness as well. I think it's now time that we move on and talk about what we can actually do about this anxiety. Because as much as it does seem very doom and gloom, that this is just how your brain is set up, that is not accurate. There is a lot that you can contribute and you can add and you can deliberately control that is going to allow you to lean into this anxiety as much as humanly possible in this moment.
人类对确定性的自然渴望。所以我们谈到了为什么会这样。我们谈到了这对你的理性、执行功能、情绪以及身体准备的心理影响。我认为现在是时候我们继续前进，谈谈我们实际上能对这种焦虑做些什么。因为尽管这看起来非常悲观，认为这只是你的大脑设置方式，但这并不准确。有很多你可以贡献、可以添加、可以刻意控制的事情，这将使你能够在这一刻尽可能地倾听这种焦虑。
So stay with us. We're going to talk about that and so much more after this short break. Pride is like love. You feel it in your heart. IR. Radio. Canada's number one streaming app for radio and podcasts, including IHart Pride Canada, your favorite hits and must have party bangers, plus personalized and curated playlists. Like back in the day pride.
所以请留下来。在短暂的休息后，我们将讨论那个以及更多内容。骄傲就像爱。你在心里感受到它。IHeart Radio。加拿大排名第一的广播和播客流媒体应用程序，包括IHeart Pride Canada，你最喜欢的流行歌曲和必备的派对热曲，加上个性化和策划的播放列表。就像过去时代的骄傲。
Come together, celebrate love. Take pride with you anytime, anywhere. Just ask your smart speaker to play IHeart Pride Canada. Stream us on your phone or listen now at iHeartRadio.ca. In the moment, it felt like it was going on forever. I didn't think I was going to live. I was terrified. There was no anything inside those eyes.
聚在一起，庆祝爱。随时随地带着骄傲。只需让你的智能音箱播放IHeart Pride Canada。在你的手机上流媒体播放，或立即在iHeartRadio.ca收听。那一刻，感觉好像永远在持续。我没想过我会活下来。我吓坏了。那些眼睛里什么都没有。
They turned black. It scared the hell out of me. That was your first murder case? Yes, sir. Fear to say this was the biggest case of your career? Yes, sir. Rape a murder for a child. This is as bad as it gets.
它们变成了黑色。这把我吓坏了。那是你的第一个谋杀案吗？是的，长官。害怕说这是你职业生涯中最大的案件吗？是的，长官。强奸并谋杀了一个孩子。这是最糟糕的情况。
I would think so. Evil, wake up. I'm the one that saw the murder take place by Crevette and DePippo. Anthony DePippo showed no signs of remorse, appearing unfazed after being sentenced to the maximum. I said I'm not guilty. I'll take it to the grief. Listen to the devil's quarry on the Iheart radio app,
我想是这样。邪恶，醒醒。我就是那个目睹了Crevette和DePippo谋杀案的人。安东尼·德皮波在被判处最高刑罚后表现得毫无悔意，看起来泰然自若。我说我没有罪。我会把这件事带进坟墓。请在IHeart Radio应用程序上收听《魔鬼采石场》，
Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. And to hear the devil's quarry ad, with exclusive content. Subscribe to Love for Good Plus on Apple Podcasts. Hey, I'm Hoda Kotby, host of the podcast, Joy 101 with Hoda Kotby. Together, we're going to have meaningful conversations with the world's most fascinating people. Like when actress Olivia Munn shared how she overcame fierce health challenges. I've gone through breast cancer and then helped my mother through breast cancer,
Apple Podcasts，或您获取播客的任何地方。要收听带有独家内容的《魔鬼采石场》广告，请在Apple Podcasts上订阅Love for Good Plus。嘿，我是霍达·科特比，播客《快乐101与霍达·科特比》的主持人。我们将一起与世界上最迷人的人进行有意义的对话。就像女演员奥利维亚·穆恩（Olivia Munn）分享她如何克服严峻的健康挑战时。我经历过乳腺癌，然后帮助我的母亲度过了乳腺癌，
and that was more difficult. There's a lot of people who understand postpartner depression. I was not prepared for postpartum anxiety. Listen to Joy 101 with Hoda Kotby on the Iheart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Because their new star is Javier T. Torito Hernandez. Everyone sees me as a football player, but before anything else, I'm human. Every single day I'm still learning how to live with problems, mistakes, relationships, emotions, ever since I was born. And I still have so many questions.
那更困难。有很多人了解产后抑郁症。我没有为产后焦虑做好准备。请在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《快乐101与霍达·科特比》。因为他们的新星是哈维尔·“小豌豆”·埃尔南德斯。每个人都视我为足球运动员，但首先，我是一个人。从出生起，我每天都在学习如何处理问题、错误、人际关系和情绪。我仍然有很多问题。
Where do we come from? What happens after death? How do you deal with cancellation? Christian or Messi Do aliens exist? What is love? Real Madrid or Barza From every day
我们从哪里来？死后会发生什么？你如何处理取消？克里斯蒂安还是梅西？有外星人吗？什么是爱？皇家马德里还是巴萨？从每天
and ordinary to the deep and extraordinary This isn't a normal podcast Everything here is spontaneous, real and genuine This podcast is like a deep talk With your closest friends Where vulnerability comes out
平凡到深刻和非凡。这不是一个普通的播客。这里的一切都是自发的、真实的、真诚的。这个播客就像一次深度谈话。和你最亲密的朋友。脆弱感显露出来。
Conspiracy theories End up on the table And goals and lessons are shared All in this life has a order perfect And all is just Wait, waitin me, I'm I'm going to be able to come out
阴谋论。被摆上桌面。目标和教训被分享。所有这一切在生活中都有完美的秩序。一切都只是……等等，等等我，我……我将能够出来。
We are here to connect The Chichariot I'm Javier and Chacharito-A-R-Landes, and together with I-Hard Radio, we're going to make the ordinary, extraordinary. Stay close. It is a carac. Wow. Listen to learning to be human on I-Had Radio, Apple Podcasts, or whatever you get your podcast. Here's something that should not be as complicated as it is, getting a racist statue removed. And here's something that should be a whole lot easier than it is, getting a new one put up in its place.
我们在这里连接。小豌豆。我是哈维尔·“小豌豆”·埃尔南德斯，与IHeart Radio一起，我们将让平凡变得非凡。保持密切关注。这是一个carac。哇。请在IHeart Radio、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《学习做人》。这里有一件事本不该如此复杂，那就是移除种族主义雕像。而这里有一件事本该比现在容易得多，那就是在原处竖立一座新的雕像。
As long as there's a politics of race in America, there's going to be a politics of race. of remembering the Civil War. To get to school, I had to go down Robert Ely Boulevard. Get to the grocery store, I had to go down Jefferson Davis Parkway. If you're an historian and you leave out half of what the history is, you're not doing your job. I'm Akila Hughes. In Rebel Spirit, Season 2 goes deep on both of those things. The fights, the politics, the people who won, and my personal campaign to add something
只要美国存在种族政治，就会存在关于内战记忆的种族政治。为了去学校，我必须走罗伯特·李大道（Robert Ely Boulevard）。去杂货店，我必须走杰斐逊·戴维斯大道（Jefferson Davis Parkway）。如果你是一位历史学家，却遗漏了一半的历史，你就没有做好你的工作。我是阿凯拉·休斯。《反叛精神》第二季深入探讨了这两件事。斗争、政治、获胜的人，以及我个人的运动，旨在为肯塔基州议会大厦增加一些真正值得墙面空间的东西。我们不仅仅是我们的身体。我们包含本质。我们包含精神。你如何代表这一点？他们只是在火上浇油，这真的正在蔓延。你会明白我的意思。请在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《反叛精神》第二季。
to the Kentucky State House that's actually worth the wall space. We are more than our bodies. We contain essence. We contain spirit. How do you represent that? They are just fueling a fire that is really catching. You'll see what I mean. Listen to Rebel Spirit Season 2 on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
（注：此段落与47段内容重叠，已在47段翻译中涵盖）
Okay, so we've talked about the negatives of worrying, which I feel like we shouldn't really linger on for much longer. And we know that anxiety of this kind isn't good for us. What are we going to do to actually address this? the quote I always try and come back to as like a touchstone in situations like this is that when we catastrophes we suffer twice we suffer once in response to an imagined reality and then again maybe if that reality does come true but we always suffer even if it doesn't come true like we suffer as a form of insurance almost and again it is about reiterating to yourself, like how often do the worst case scenarios actually happen? It's a good reminder not to borrow
好的，所以我们谈到了担心的负面影响，我觉得我们不应该再纠结于此了。我们知道这种焦虑对我们没有好处。我们要怎么做才能真正解决这个问题？我总是试图回到的一句名言，作为这种情况下的试金石，那就是当我们灾难化时，我们遭受了两次痛苦。我们因回应一个想象的现实而遭受一次痛苦，然后如果那个现实真的实现了，可能又会遭受一次，但即使它没有实现，我们也总是遭受痛苦——我们遭受痛苦几乎是一种保险形式。再说一遍，这是关于向自己重申，最坏的情况发生的频率有多高？这是一个很好的提醒，不要从未来借用
grief and sadness and stress from the future because chances are it won't happen exactly the way you imagined anyways. Secondly, your level of coping is often something that you underestimate, just as much as you overestimate how terrible the situation is going to be. And like this excessive worry doesn't actually leave you more prepared. So you can't keep listening to your brain. as it tries to convince you that it will. So we need an alternative. And what I think the alternative is is this. If you can overthink the negatives of a situation, you are just as capable, if not more capable than most, of overthinking the positives as well. This is essentially a form of emotional replacement therapy, right? It's like replacing like, I don't know, alcohol for a non-alcoholic
悲伤和压力，因为很有可能它不会完全按照你想象的方式发生。其次，你的应对水平通常是你低估的东西，就像你高估了情况会有多糟糕一样。而且这种过度的担心实际上并没有让你准备得更充分。所以你不能继续听从你的大脑，因为它试图说服你它会。所以我们需要一个替代方案。我认为替代方案是这样的。如果你能过度思考情况的负面影响，你同样有能力，甚至比大多数人更有能力，去过度思考积极的一面。这本质上是一种情绪替代疗法，对吧？就像用非酒精饮料代替酒精，或者用尼古丁口香糖代替香烟。用积极的过度思考来代替你的负面过度思考恶习。把你大脑目前为你烹饪的关于你的未来或全球未来的任何可怕的最坏情况拿出来，相反，有意识地、刻意地想象所有它可能进展顺利的方式。即使它感觉极其乐观和愚蠢，即使它感觉是妄想，给自己设定一个挑战。任何时候你对未来有负面评估，任何时候你发现自己在灾难化，写下五个以积极的“如果……会怎样”结尾的替代方案。你知道，你的大脑，
beverage or like a cigarette for a nicotine gum. Replace your negative overthinking vice with positive overthinking. Take any terrible worst case scenario that your brain is currently cooking up for you about your future or the global future and instead consciously, deliberately imagine all the ways that it could go right. Even if it feels ridiculously optimistic and stupid, even if it feels delusional, set yourself a challenge. Anytime you have a negative assessment of the future, anytime you find yourself catastrophizing, write down five alternatives that end with a positive what if. You know, your brain is,
再次强调，有这种负面偏见，它会放大“如果……会怎样，插入最坏情况”的想法。你仍然被允许有“如果……会怎样”的想法。你的大脑仍然被允许有那种对想象力或假设的偏好，但让它们成为积极的假设。把“如果……会怎样”变成一些更积极、更有想象力和活力的事情。它可能不会改变你的现实，对吧？但那不是目标。目标再次是不要遭受两次痛苦。目标是让你在最坏的情况发生时，在心理上、生理上和情感上做好更充分的准备，因为你还没有在你想象它时就已经耗尽了自己，耗尽了你所有的心理资源。
again, having this negativity bias whereby it's going to amplify the what if insert worst case scenario here. You are still allowed to have the what if. Your brain is still allowed to have that preference for imagination or that preference for hypotheticals, but make them positive hypotheticals. Turn the what if into something that's a bit more positively imaginative and vibrant. It might not change your reality, right? But that is not the objective. The objective is again, not to suffer twice. The objective is to keep yourself more mentally prepared and physically prepared and emotionally prepared for if the worst case scenario does happen because you haven't already exhausted yourself and exhausted all your mental resources as you were imagining it.
就像这唯一的目的不是为了改变现实。再说一遍，只是为了让你不要遭受两次痛苦。这个策略被这位研究员，这位行为研究科学家艾莉森·伍德（Alison Wood）更进一步，她建议应对我们对未来恐惧的一种方法是将我们的焦虑重新标记为兴奋。我们之前谈过这个，但在她的工作中，艾莉森调查了人们对让他们非常恐惧、非常害怕、紧张的任务的反应，比如公开演讲、与老板会面、第一次约会。她发现，在大多数情况下，当人们进入这种情况时，他们认为在事前能做的最有效的事情就是冷静下来，并试图强烈地忽略他们感受到的不舒服的感觉。当他们面对这种情况，当他们面对这种对未来的焦虑时，他们确实相信我能做的最好的事情就是忽略它。
Like the only objective of this is not to change the reality. Again, it's just so that you don't suffer twice. This strategy was taken a step further by this researcher, this behavioral research scientist called Alison Wood, who suggested that a way of coping with our fears about the future is to relabel our anxiety as excitement. And we've spoken about this before, but in her work, Alison, she investigated people's responses to tasks that made them really fearful, made them really scared, nervous, things like public speaking, meeting with a boss, a first date. And what she found was that in most cases, as people were entering this situation, the most effective thing they thought they could do beforehand was to calm down and was to intensely try and ignore the uncomfortable feelings that they were feeling. When they faced this situation, when they faced this anxiety about the future, they really did believe the best thing I can do is ignore it.
而她的研究发现，这实际上让我们更多地思考焦虑的感觉。我想，这叫什么？就像白熊、白象效应。当我告诉你不要去想一只白象时，你首先会想到的就是一只白象。当你告诉自己，我不应该焦虑，我不应该焦虑，你只会更焦虑。所以相反，接受这种感觉，承认它，更深刻地感受它，
And what her research found was that actually made us think about the anxious feeling more. It's like, I think, what is it called? Like the white bear, the white elephant effect. When I tell you not to think about a white elephant, the first thing you're going to think about is a white elephant. When you tell yourself, I shouldn't be anxious, I shouldn't be anxious, you're just going to be more anxious. So instead, take the feeling, acknowledge it, feel it more deeply,
但相反，说，这是兴奋。我对可能性感到兴奋。我对未来感到兴奋。这种焦虑是激活性的。它总是会，而且总是像任何类型的唤醒一样，使用相同的神经和生物学模式，包括积极的唤醒和兴奋。所以这取决于解释。你有能力接受这种焦虑的感觉，如果可能的话，如果你做得对，把它
but instead say, this is excitement. I'm excited about the possibility. I'm excited about the future. This anxiety is activating. It always will and it always does, like activate and uses the same neural and biological patterns as any type of arousal, including positive arousal and excitement. So it is up for interpretation. You are able to take this anxious feeling and if possible and if you do it right, switch it
转换成一种表明机会的感觉，一种表明最好的或好的事情即将到来的感觉，那些你无法预料的事情。这有意义吗？本质上，这只是一种认知重评，就像，只是为了使用心理学术语。我认为这对于关于我们个人未来的焦虑特别强大。就像，我会交到朋友吗？我会找到工作吗？我能度过下一个篇章吗？
into a feeling that indicates opportunity and a feeling that indicates the best or that good things are coming, things that you cannot anticipate. Does that kind of make sense? Like, essentially it's just a form of cognitive reappraisal, like, just to use the psychology term for it. This is, I think, particularly powerful for anxiety about our personal futures. Like, am I going to make friends? Am I going to find a job? Am I going to survive the next chapter.
转化为一种预示着机遇的感觉，一种预示着最好的结果或好事即将发生的感觉，那些你无法预料的事情。这听起来有道理吗？就像，本质上它只是一种认知重评，用心理学术语来说就是这样。我认为这对于缓解我们对个人未来的焦虑特别有效。比如，我能交到朋友吗？我能找到工作吗？我能度过人生的下一个篇章吗？
I just think that viewing ambiguity as an opportunity for greatness and viewing the blank slate as a an opportunity for possibility. It doesn't, again, it doesn't change the reality, but it changes how you cope, it changes how you act and it changes how you feel. And that is really what we're trying to target. I think it's equally valuable if you are having a lot of fear about your future to shrink down your timeline a little bit. Instead of asking, you know, what is my life going to look like in five years and being obsessively worried about controlling everything up until that five year mark, instead of constantly asking what's my life going to look like in 10 years, I'm at ever going to be happy, just zoom in a little bit. Zoom into what you could do in the next week,
我只是认为，将不确定性视为成就伟大的机会，将空白的起点视为充满可能性的契机。这并不能改变现实，但它会改变你应对的方式，改变你的行动，也会改变你的感受。而这正是我们想要达到的目标。我认为，如果你对未来感到非常恐惧，那么缩短你的时间跨度也是同样有价值的。不要去问“五年后我的生活会是什么样”，也不要执着于控制五年内的每一件事；不要总是问“十年后我的生活会是什么样”、“我以后会幸福吗”，试着把目光拉近一点。把目光聚焦在你下周能做的事情上，
what you could do this weekend that would be meaningful or productive. What can you achieve in two months rather than projecting yourself further and further into the future, then your current abilities would actually allow you to control. And this isn't about lowering your ambition. It's about redirecting your intention to a time frame where your actions actually have power. This is the big thing about our anxiety about the future. Again, it actually makes us less capable of managing the future because it keeps us focused on things that are further and further out of our reach. There is very little that you can do right now that would all out guarantee how your life would look like in five or ten years.
聚焦于这个周末你能做些什么有意义或有成效的事情。与其不断地把自己投射到比你目前能力所能控制的更遥远的未来，不如想想你在两个月内能实现什么。这并不是要降低你的抱负，而是要将你的意图重新导向一个你的行动真正能发挥作用的时间框架。这就是我们对未来焦虑的核心所在。再说一次，它实际上让我们更难掌控未来，因为它让我们专注于那些越来越遥不可及的事情。你现在几乎没有什么办法能百分之百保证你五年或十年后的生活会是什么样子。
and getting to that point requires you to take action now. The thing is, is that obsessively worrying about whether the action you're taking now is going to have the positive effect on your future that you want it to, often counterintuitively means that we don't actually take that necessary action that we know is right, because we are so cognitively overwhelmed and mentally overwhelmed with the possibilities of it going wrong. So condense your time frame, try any possible strategy you have to just refocus on the present, refocus on the next couple of weeks. And I would also say if you're really dealing with some incredible personal anxiety about the future,
要达到那个目标，需要你现在就采取行动。问题在于，过度担心你现在的行动是否会产生你想要的积极影响，往往会适得其反，导致我们实际上没有采取那些我们明知是正确的必要行动，因为我们被事情出错的可能性在认知和心理上压得喘不过气来。所以，缩短你的时间框架，尝试任何可能的策略来重新专注于当下，重新专注于接下来的几周。我还想说，如果你真的在处理一些关于未来的巨大个人焦虑，
use history as your compass. Really dig into your memory to provide relief. Essentially, remember the times in the past where you thought the worst case scenario was all but search. and actually it didn't happen. Try and remember previous experiences where you entered a room and you thought it was going to be terrible. When you got on a flight and you thought you were going to be scared, when you moved to a new city and you thought you'd never make friends, and how far removed you are from that negative situation. Now, how differently things turned out.
请以历史为指南。深入挖掘你的记忆来寻求慰藉。本质上，回想一下过去那些你认为最坏的情况即将发生，但实际上并没有发生的时刻。试着回想一下以前的经历：当你走进一个房间，以为会很糟糕的时候；当你坐上飞机，以为会很害怕的时候；当你搬到一个新城市，以为永远交不到朋友的时候。看看你现在离那些负面情况有多远，看看事情的结果是多么不同。
the best antidote to my future anxieties is just calling out how they have never been accurate in the past. Never. Like my anxiety is such an unreliable narrator. It has never been right about a situation. So why do I keep believing it? Why do you keep believing it? And if you can remember a time, it has been right. And if you're wanting to use that as evidence that it might be.
对抗未来焦虑最好的解药，就是指出它们在过去从未准确过。从来没有。我的焦虑就像一个不可靠的叙述者。它对任何情况的判断从来没对过。所以我为什么要一直相信它？你为什么要一直相信它？如果你能想起它曾经对过的一次，并且你想用那次作为证据来证明它可能……
right in the future, think about the fact that you are still here and that you still found a way to cope. Because so often when we have these negative assessments, again, we don't think about the coping, we just think about how terrible the feeling is going to be. We just remove and suddenly forget that we have agency and that we'll be able to ever do anything about it. This is where I really want to talk about the philosophy of Marcus Aurelius, who used this strategy, I guess, used this idea called negative visualization. And essentially what he said was that, or what he thought or believed was that to manage anxiety about the future and to manage this catastrophizing anxiety spiral that a lot of us face every single day, much like that research
在未来也是对的，那么请想想这样一个事实：你依然在这里，而且你依然找到了应对的方法。因为当我们进行这些负面评估时，我们往往不会去想如何应对，而只是在想那种感觉会有多糟糕。我们只是移除了应对能力，突然忘记了我们拥有主观能动性，忘记了我们总能做些什么来改变现状。在这里，我真的想谈谈马可·奥勒留的哲学，他使用了一种策略，我想称之为“消极想象”。本质上，他所说的是，或者他所认为的是，为了管理对未来的焦虑，为了管理我们许多人每天都要面对的这种灾难化焦虑螺旋，就像那项研究……
from that doctor who talked about turning anxiety into excitement, let your self. think about those worst-case scenarios. Do the last thing that your brain expects you to do. Let yourself experience that anxiety more. Picture all the terrible things and then add in all the ways that you're going to cope. With negative visualization, what he would do is that every single day, I think he would think of all the different things that could go wrong, all the different ways that his day could go terribly, and then he would visualize all the ways that he was going to cope. He would visualize all the different ways that he was going to survive that. And we can do that for the larger scale things as well. We can do that for the situation I always think is a big fear for
那位医生谈到将焦虑转化为兴奋，让自己去思考那些最坏的情况。做你大脑最不希望你做的事。让自己更多地体验那种焦虑。想象所有糟糕的事情，然后加上你将如何应对的所有方法。通过消极想象，他每天都会思考所有可能出错的事情，思考他的一天可能变得糟糕的所有方式，然后他会想象他将如何应对的所有方法。他会想象他将如何从那些困境中幸存下来的各种方式。我们也可以对更大规模的事情这样做。我们可以针对我一直认为是我们最大的恐惧的情况来做……
us, which is like, what if I lose my job? What if like AI takes my industry? What if this, what if that? What if I'm no longer needed? What if all this study was to waste? What if all my skills were to waste? And we get into the spiral of like, I'm going to end up destitute. I'm going to end up homeless. What Marcus Aurelius would say would be take that situation, Yeah, it all going terribly wrong. Now imagine five different ways that you could cope. The skills that you could regain. The soft skills that you could, I don't know, fine tune, the new career path that you could pivot into, the skill that you have that this technology doesn't, the way that you could go back to school, the way that you could start your own business. Like that is the
比如：如果我失业了怎么办？如果人工智能取代了我的行业怎么办？如果这个怎么办，那个怎么办？如果我不再被需要了怎么办？如果我所有的学习都白费了怎么办？如果我所有的技能都浪费了怎么办？我们陷入了“我最终会变得一无所有”、“我最终会流落街头”的螺旋。马可·奥勒留会说，接受那种情况，是的，一切都变得非常糟糕。现在想象五种你可以应对的方法。你可以重新获得的技能，你可以微调的软技能，你可以转型进入的新职业道路，你拥有的这项技术所不具备的技能，你可以重返校园的方式，你可以创业的方式。这就是……
part of this equation that we never spend time on and that our mind never spends time on. That's just one example, obviously. But again, re-center your agency rather than letting the fear be the only dominant feeling. Let's finish up this episode by turning our attention back to our larger anxieties about the world, the high-level fear that everything is going to shit, everything is terrible, everything is a disaster, which honestly feels accurate sometimes. but how do we navigate those anxieties, especially because, yes, we've talked about re-centering agency, but our agency is probably more limited in these cases. So some of those personal strategies are not going to be as effective. I have a couple of alternatives. I have three things for you to try in these situations where you're really spirally about
我们从未花时间去思考，而我们的大脑也从未花时间去思考的等式部分。这显然只是一个例子。但同样，重新找回你的主观能动性，而不是让恐惧成为唯一的主导情绪。让我们通过将注意力转回我们对世界更大的焦虑来结束这一集，那种认为一切都在变糟、一切都很糟糕、一切都是灾难的高层恐惧，说实话，有时感觉确实如此。但我们该如何应对这些焦虑呢？尤其是因为，是的，我们谈到了重新找回能动性，但在这些情况下，我们的能动性可能更加有限。所以，其中一些个人策略不会那么有效。我有几个替代方案。在这些你真的对……
the future of the world. The first is, again, a reminder that if you care, others must care as well. when we feel anxious about large scale, I don't even want to call them issues, disasters, emergencies, whatever it is. Part of what intensifies that anxiety is something called pluralistic ignorance. This is a cognitive bias where we assume that our private concerns aren't shared by anybody else, even when they are. Because really, we can only ever know and fully feel our own thoughts. what this means is that we look around and we're like, how come nobody else is worried about this? How come nobody is caring about this? And suddenly your level of concern feels very isolating.
世界未来感到焦虑的情况下，我有三件事让你尝试。第一，再次提醒自己，如果你关心，别人也一定关心。当我们对大规模的——我甚至不想称之为问题，而是灾难、紧急情况，无论是什么——感到焦虑时，加剧这种焦虑的部分原因被称为“多元无知”。这是一种认知偏差，即我们假设自己的私人担忧没有被其他人分享，即使事实并非如此。因为实际上，我们只能真正了解并完全感受到自己的想法。这意味着我们环顾四周，心想：为什么没有其他人担心这个？为什么没有人关心这个？突然间，你的担忧程度让你感到非常孤立。
It feels much larger than you can cope with because you are just one tiny person. So it is important to keep focus, to keep in touch with, to keep your attention on the ways that other people do care. To actively seek out communities, people, pages that show and give evidence. for the fact that other people are concerned, other people are actively contributing, other people are helping so that you don't only end up seeing the world as this negative place where you are the only good person. Remember, the world is good because you are in it and you are good people. Don't let yourself get buried under the sense that you are the only one who is living through these awful times and having the reactions you are. Most people are feeling
它让你觉得比你能应对的要大得多，因为你只是一个渺小的人。所以，保持专注，保持联系，把注意力放在其他人关心的方式上是很重要的。积极寻找那些展示并提供证据的社区、人群、页面，证明其他人也在担忧，其他人也在积极贡献，其他人也在提供帮助，这样你就不会只把世界看作是一个只有你是好人的负面地方。记住，世界之所以美好，是因为你在其中，而且你们是好人。不要让自己被那种“只有你一个人在经历这些糟糕时期并有这种反应”的感觉所淹没。大多数人都有……
this way. Most people are having the same worries as you are. Talk to them about it. Join them in like how they are striving to make things better. Basically, more generally, like, be the change. You know, you probably can't influence world politics, but you can carry, you know, the groceries up for your elderly neighbor. You can donate your time. You can spread seeds around your local community. You can be kind to the people that you know.
这种感觉。大多数人都有和你一样的担忧。和他们谈谈。加入他们，看看他们是如何努力让事情变得更好的。基本上，更广泛地说，成为改变的一部分。你知道，你可能无法影响世界政治，但你可以帮年迈的邻居提杂货。你可以贡献你的时间。你可以在当地社区播撒种子。你可以善待你认识的人。
And I do genuinely believe that those small, tangible acts do have big, larger repercussions. And psychologically, it doesn't matter if it changes nothing. It matters in that it helps you. When we feel overwhelmed by global issues, by future uncertainty, we often fall into a state of learned helplessness, the belief that nothing we do will make a difference. And so we stop trying altogether, not just about global things, but are about personal things
我确实真诚地相信，那些微小、切实的行为确实会产生巨大的连锁反应。从心理学上讲，即使它什么都没改变也无所谓。重要的是它能帮助你。当我们被全球性问题、未来不确定性所淹没时，我们往往会陷入一种“习得性无助”的状态，即认为我们所做的一切都不会产生任何影响。所以我们完全停止了尝试，不仅是对全球性问题，对个人事务……
and personal goals and personal decisions. But small local action interrupts that pattern. It restores a sense of agency again. It restores a sense that like your behavior has an impact. And that doesn't just help for, I don't know, our global fears, but it helps in that it lets us make long-term plans for the future because it makes us and it helps us believe that a future will be there. It stops us from doing things that are impulsive, like overspending, doing things that are
个人目标和个人决定也是如此。但微小的局部行动打破了这种模式。它再次恢复了一种能动感。它恢复了一种感觉，即你的行为是有影响力的。这不仅有助于解决我们的全球恐惧，而且有助于让我们为未来制定长期计划，因为它让我们相信未来是存在的。它阻止我们做一些冲动的事情，比如过度消费，做一些……
dangerous. It lets us actually set goals. And again, this isn't about, this. it's not only about you. Like obviously we're talking about a global or a community-wide sense of despair, like a global sense of like that things are going terribly. And I know it sounds like I keep bringing it back to what you need and what you can do to make yourself feel better. But genuinely, you cannot do anything for anybody else if you do not take care of yourself. And part of taking care of yourself is taking care of others because again, there's this cycle of agency that makes you
危险的事情。它让我们能够真正设定目标。再说一次，这不仅仅是关于你。显然，我们谈论的是一种全球或社区范围内的绝望感，一种全球性的“事情正在变得非常糟糕”的感觉。我知道这听起来好像我一直在把它带回到你需要什么以及你能做什么来让自己感觉更好。但真诚地说，如果你不照顾好自己，你就无法为别人做任何事。而照顾好自己的一部分就是照顾好他人，因为再次强调，这种能动性的循环让你……
feel like you are not just one small person that all the world's events are happening to. You are part of a broader community. You're not alone in this and you're experiencing this with other people by your side. You and a pal in Montreal and Oceaga with four nights at residents in downtown Montreal. flights from Porter Airlines, two weekend gold tickets and $1,000 of cash. Please love me. Lord, Zara Larson, Tema Gray, Sombor, Sombor, 21 pilots, More. Download IHeart Radio. Listen to IHeart new music for 10 minutes and enter to win. Osiaga 2026. Every day you listen is another chance to win. In the moment, it felt like it was going on forever. I didn't think I was going to live. I was
觉得你不仅仅是一个渺小的、任由世界事件摆布的人。你是更广泛社区的一部分。你并不孤单，你正与身边的人一起经历这一切。你和一位朋友在蒙特利尔，在蒙特利尔市中心享受四晚住宿。波特航空的机票，两张周末黄金门票和1000美元现金。请爱我。上帝，Zara Larson, Tema Gray, Sombor, 21 pilots等等。下载IHeart Radio。收听IHeart新音乐10分钟即可参与赢取。Osiaga 2026。你收听的每一天都是赢取奖品的机会。在那一刻，感觉就像过了很久。我以为我活不下来了。我……
terrified. There was no anything inside those eyes. They turned black. It scared the hell out of me. That was your first murder case? Yes, sir. Fair to say this was the biggest case of your career? Yes, sir. Rape a murder for a child. Just as bad as it gets. I would think so.
吓坏了。那些眼睛里没有任何东西。它们变成了黑色。这把我吓坏了。那是你的第一起谋杀案吗？是的，长官。可以说这是你职业生涯中最大的案件吗？是的，长官。强奸并谋杀一名儿童。这是最糟糕的情况了。我想是的。
People, wake up. I'm the one that saw the murder take place by Creveit and DePippo. Anthony DePippo showed no signs of remorse, appearing unfazed after being sentenced to the maximum. I said I'm not guilty. I'll take it to the grief. Listen to the devil's quarry on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever.
人们，醒醒吧。我是那个亲眼目睹了Creveit和DePippo谋杀案的人。Anthony DePippo在被判处最高刑罚后，没有表现出任何悔意，看起来若无其事。我说我没有罪。我会把这件事带进坟墓。在Iheart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何地方收听《魔鬼的采石场》。
you get your podcasts. And to hear the devil's quarry ad free with exclusive content, subscribe to LaVa for Good Plus on Apple Podcasts. Hey, I'm Hoda Kotby, host of the podcast, Joy 101 with Hoda Kotby. Together, we're going to have meaningful conversations with the world's most fascinating people, like when actress Olivia Munn shared how she overcame fierce health challenges. I've gone through breast cancer and then helped my mother through breast cancer, and that was more difficult.
你获取播客的地方。想要收听无广告且包含独家内容的《魔鬼的采石场》，请在Apple Podcasts上订阅LaVa for Good Plus。嘿，我是Hoda Kotby，播客《Joy 101 with Hoda Kotby》的主持人。我们将一起与世界上最迷人的人进行有意义的对话，比如女演员Olivia Munn分享她如何克服严峻的健康挑战。“我经历过乳腺癌，然后又帮助我母亲度过了乳腺癌，那更困难。”
There's a lot of people who understand postpartner depression. I was not prepared for postpartum anxiety. Listen to Joy 101 with Hoda Kotby on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Because their new star is Javier T. Tarito Hernandez. Everyone sees me as a football player, but before anything else, I'm human. Every single day, I'm still learning how to live with problems, mistakes, relationships, emotions, ever since I was born. And I still have so many questions. Where do we come from?
“有很多人了解产后抑郁症。但我没有为产后焦虑做好准备。”在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《Joy 101 with Hoda Kotby》。因为他们的新星是Javier T. Tarito Hernandez。每个人都把我视为一名足球运动员，但在任何其他身份之前，我首先是一个人。从我出生起，每一天我都在学习如何处理问题、错误、人际关系和情绪。我仍然有很多问题。我们从哪里来？
What happens after death? How do you deal with cancellation? Cristiano or Messi? Do aliens exist? What is love? Real Madrid or Barza? From every day and ordinary to the deep and extraordinary. This isn't a normal podcast.
死后会发生什么？你如何处理取消文化？C罗还是梅西？外星人存在吗？什么是爱？皇家马德里还是巴萨？从日常琐事到深刻非凡。这不是一个普通的播客。
Everything here is spontaneous, real and genuine. This podcast is like a deep talk with your closest friends. Where vulnerability comes out. Conspiracy theories end up on the table and goals and lessons are shared. All in this life has a order perfect and all is just. Wait. I'm going to pressuram. We are here to connect.
这里的一切都是自发的、真实的、真诚的。这个播客就像与你最亲密的朋友进行深入交谈。脆弱的一面展现出来。阴谋论被摆上桌面，目标和经验被分享。生命中的一切都有完美的秩序，一切都是公正的。等等。我要去……我们在这里是为了建立联系。
The Chicharito. Oh, Javier El Chicharro-Randes. And together with I-Hard Radio, we're going to make the ordinary, extraordinary. Stay close. It is a carac. Wow. Listen to learning to be human on IHard Radio,
Chicharito。哦，Javier El Chicharro-Randes。与I-Hard Radio一起，我们将让平凡变得非凡。保持关注。这是一个……哇。在IHard Radio、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《学习做人》。
Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. Here's something that should not be as complicated as it is. Getting a racist statue removed. And here's something that should be a whole lot easier than it is. Getting a new one put up in its place. As long as there's a politics of race in America, there's going to be a politics of remembering the Civil War. To get to school, I had to go down Robert Ely Boulevard.
这里有一些本不该如此复杂的事情：移除种族主义雕像。还有一些本该容易得多的事情：在原处放置一个新的。只要美国存在种族政治，就会有关于内战记忆的政治。为了去学校，我必须经过罗伯特·李大道。
Get to the grocery store. I had to go down Jefferson Davis Parkway. If you're an historian and you leave out half of what the history is, you're not doing your job. I'm Akila Hughes, and Rebel Spirit season two goes deep on both of those things. The fights, the politics, the people who won, and my personal campaign to add something to the Kentucky State House that's actually worth the wall space. We are more than our bodies. We contain essence.
去杂货店，我必须经过杰斐逊·戴维斯大道。如果你是一位历史学家，却遗漏了一半的历史，那你就是在失职。我是Akila Hughes，《Rebel Spirit》第二季深入探讨了这两件事。斗争、政治、胜利者，以及我个人为肯塔基州议会大厦增加一些真正值得墙面空间的东西的运动。我们不仅仅是我们的身体。我们包含本质。
We contain spirit. How do you represent that? They are just fueling a fire that is really catching. You'll see what I mean. Listen to Rebel Spirit Season 2 on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. I also think just having some good digital and online hygiene is incredibly important if you are having a lot of anxiety about the future.
我们包含精神。你如何代表这一点？他们只是在火上浇油，这火势真的在蔓延。你会明白我的意思的。在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《Rebel Spirit》第二季。我还认为，如果你对未来有很大的焦虑，拥有良好的数字和在线卫生习惯也非常重要。
not just limiting how much terrible negative news that you are consuming, but just limiting how much online content you are engaging with full stop. I don't know about you, but I just feel like my algorithm is so angry and terrible at the moment, even when it's not about the global news. Like, I just got into this stage with my algorithm. I don't know, like we're having this relationship, but like my algorithm got to this point where everything it was showing. showing me was like people fighting or people having arguments on the street or, you know, some kind of controversy or hot take video. And genuinely I remember having this moment where I was scrolling and I was like, I have not seen a positive piece of content in ages because this is
不仅仅是限制你消费多少可怕的负面新闻，而是完全限制你参与在线内容的数量。我不知道你怎么样，但我只是觉得我的算法现在非常愤怒和糟糕，即使不是关于全球新闻。就像，我只是和我的算法进入了这个阶段。我不知道，就像我们有这种关系，但我的算法到了这样一个地步，它向我展示的一切都是人们在街上打架或争吵，或者某种争议或热点视频。我真的记得有一次我在滚动屏幕时，心想：我已经很久没有看到积极的内容了，因为这就是……
the kind of stuff that gets engagement. You know, if you are sitting on your phone constantly and that is what's being fed to you, you are not, of course, naturally going to feel good about the future because your entire mental environment is being consumed by negativity. So when we talk about digital resilience, when we talk about digital hygiene, it's not just about avoiding the news. It's about actually having guardrails against just letting whatever is being said online, whatever is going on on the internet, enter your life prominently and all the time. You know, at some point, your desire to be informed could actually turn into over-monitoring, could actually turn into an anxiety-soothing mechanism, where again, we have this anxiety about our future
那种能获得参与度的东西。你知道，如果你一直坐在手机前，而这就是被喂给你的东西，你当然不会对未来感觉良好，因为你的整个心理环境都被负面情绪所消耗。所以当我们谈论数字韧性，当我们谈论数字卫生时，这不仅仅是关于避免新闻。这是关于真正建立护栏，防止无论网上说什么、互联网上发生什么，都突出且持续地进入你的生活。你知道，在某种程度上，你想要了解信息的愿望实际上可能变成过度监控，实际上可能变成一种焦虑缓解机制，在这里，我们再次对未来……
and this anxiety about the world, such that we, like, dig further in and we look for more information and we look for more, I don't know, more knowledge about what's happening. And it becomes counteractive. It becomes more harmful than it is good. So it is okay to stay. It is okay to step back, it is okay to be like, I don't actually want to, you know, belair terrible world events into my eyes at all time and to just choose to put boundaries around it. Choose to only look at the news for 20 minutes on your lunch break. Choose again to not have your phone in bed with you, to not be engaging with content online that is making you feel negative about the world, not listening to true crime, not always like engaging with the violent content.
和世界感到焦虑，以至于我们深入挖掘，寻找更多信息，寻找更多关于正在发生的事情的知识。这变得适得其反。它变得弊大于利。所以退后一步是可以的，说“我其实不想一直让可怕的世界事件进入我的眼睛”是可以的，选择为它设定界限是可以的。选择只在午休时间看20分钟新闻。再次选择不要把手机带上床，不要参与网上让你对世界感到负面的内容，不听真实犯罪，不总是参与暴力内容。
and I do actually think that that's going to make you feel better about not just the global future, but your future as well. Just like balancing your need to be informed and your need for closure or predictability with also your human need to just like have some peace and just to exist and just to not feel guilty about experiencing some level of joy. I think as I wrap up this episode, let me just say if you're in your 20s, I think it would be abnormal to not have anxiety about the future, right? It is like the most normal feeling to have this feeling right now that you don't know and that you are unsure and that you really could do with somebody in your life who had
我确实认为这会让你感觉更好，不仅是对全球未来，对你自己的未来也是如此。就像平衡你了解信息和寻求终结或可预测性的需求，同时也平衡你作为人类需要获得一些平静、仅仅存在、不对体验某种程度的快乐感到内疚的需求。我想在结束这一集时，让我说，如果你在20多岁，对未来没有焦虑才是不正常的，对吧？现在有这种感觉，觉得你不知道，你不确定，你真的需要生活中有一个人……
the crystal ball who could just like tell you how it's going to work out. So have some kindness for yourself, have some grace, like just give yourself a little bit of credit. You are building a life, you are building something that has never been built before, right? your life, the blueprint for your life, is completely individual, completely up to you. There is no guidebook. There is nobody who can tell you that it's going to be okay. And so facing up against all of those possibilities and the unpredictability of this moment is really emotionally taxing. And it is okay to sometimes feel like it is not going to work out as you
拥有水晶球，能告诉你事情会如何发展，这是最正常的感觉。所以对自己好一点，优雅一点，给自己一点肯定。你正在建立一种生活，你正在建立一些以前从未建立过的东西，对吧？你的生活，你生活的蓝图，是完全个人的，完全取决于你。没有指南。没有人能告诉你一切都会好起来的。所以面对所有这些可能性和这一刻的不可预测性，在情感上确实很累人。有时感觉事情不会按照你……
would like it to. The thing is, is that it so often does. And the thing to remind yourself is that those worst case scenarios that your brain is cooking up, that they're trying to protect you, aren't always going to come true. And in fact, most of the time it is better than you expected, or it is in fact just neutral and you end up coping anyways. So it's totally normal. You will make it through this. Do not let your anxiety dominate all the other good things that are happening in your life. And when it comes to your anxieties about the future, about political uncertainty, about global uncertainty, again, I keep saying give yourself some grace, but just please do remind yourself and please do remember that there is good in the world, that people are actively taking care of problems,
想要的方式发展也是正常的。问题是，它往往会发展得很好。要提醒自己的是，你大脑中编造的那些最坏的情况，它们试图保护你，但并不总是会成真。事实上，大多数时候它比你预期的要好，或者实际上只是中性的，你最终还是会应对过来。所以这完全正常。你会度过难关的。不要让你的焦虑主导你生活中所有其他正在发生的好的事情。当谈到你对未来的焦虑，对政治不确定性，对全球不确定性的焦虑时，我再次说要对自己宽容一些，但请务必提醒自己并记住，世界上有美好，人们正在积极解决问题，
looking out for problems, helping people in their community. You can be one of those people. And then additionally, you know, sometimes it is okay to take a break from that. And it is okay to not always be plugged in to all the terrors of the world. if it means that you can be a better community member, if it means that you can do more for the people around you. So that is me getting off my soapbox. We are done for the day. I hope that this has made you feel a little bit better about whatever is going on in your life and how you're feeling about the world around you. If you have made it this far, leave a little emoji down below that symbolizes hope to you, especially if you're listening on Spotify. Maybe share this episode
关注问题，帮助社区中的人们。你可以成为这些人中的一员。此外，你知道，有时从这些事情中休息一下是可以的。不总是沉浸在世界的恐怖中是可以的。如果这意味着你可以成为一个更好的社区成员，如果这意味着你可以为你周围的人做更多的事情。这就是我结束我的长篇大论。我们今天就到这里。我希望这让你对生活中正在发生的事情以及你对周围世界的感受感觉好了一些。如果你已经听到了这里，在下方留下一个象征希望的表情符号，特别是如果你是在Spotify上收听的话。也许分享这一集……
with a friend who is also feeling a lot of anxiety about the future of their lives and the future of the world, who you think could really benefit from this episode. Make sure that you are following us on Instagram at That Psychology Podcast. You can also follow us on Substack. You can watch us on Netflix. There is so much that you can do. All of it will be in the description down below. But especially when it comes to this topic in this episode, be safe, be kind and most certainly be gentle with yourself. We will talk very, very soon. There was no anything inside those eyes. They turned black.
给一个也对他们生活的未来和世界的未来感到非常焦虑的朋友，你认为他们能从这一集中受益。确保你在Instagram上关注我们@ThatPsychologyPodcast。你也可以在Substack上关注我们。你可以在Netflix上观看我们。你可以做的事情太多了。所有这些都会在下方的描述中。但特别是当谈到这一集的主题时，注意安全，保持善良，最重要的是，对自己温柔一点。我们很快就会再聊。那些眼睛里没有任何东西。它们变成了黑色。
It scared the hell out of me. Evil, wake up. I'm the one that saw the murder take place by Crevec and DePippo. Anthony DePippo showed no signs of remorse, appearing unfazed after being sentenced to the maximum. I said I'm not guilty. I'll take it to the grief. Listen to the devil's quarry in the Bone Valley Feed on the Eye
这把我吓坏了。邪恶，醒醒吧。我是那个亲眼目睹了Crevec和DePippo谋杀案的人。Anthony DePippo在被判处最高刑罚后，没有表现出任何悔意，看起来若无其事。我说我没有罪。我会把这件事带进坟墓。在Bone Valley Feed中收听《魔鬼的采石场》，在I……
Heart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, wherever you get your podcasts. Joy is essential, and it's also elusive, but now there's a new and exciting way to start your journey toward a more joyful existence, Joy 101. It's a new podcast hosted by me, How to Coppe. If you're craving inspiration to maximize your joy, tune into these candid, uplifting, and moving on-air chats. Open your free IHeart Radio app. Search Joy 101 and listen now.
Heart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方。快乐是必不可少的，它也是难以捉摸的，但现在有一种新的、令人兴奋的方式来开始你通往更快乐生活的旅程——《Joy 101》。这是一个由我How to Coppe主持的新播客。如果你渴望获得灵感来最大化你的快乐，请收听这些坦诚、振奋人心且感人的直播聊天。打开你免费的IHeart Radio应用程序。搜索《Joy 101》并立即收听。
Joy 101 with Hoda Kotfi is presented by CVS. Everyone sees me as a football player, but before anything else, I'm human. Every single day I'm still learning how to live with problems, mistakes, relationships, emotions ever since I was born. This isn't a normal podcast. Everything here is spontaneous, real, and genuine, just honest conversations about what it means to be alive. I'm Javier Tornandez, and listen to Learning to Be Human on IHard Radio, Apple Podcasts,
《Joy 101 with Hoda Kotfi》由CVS呈现。每个人都把我视为一名足球运动员，但在任何其他身份之前，我首先是一个人。从我出生起，每一天我都在学习如何处理问题、错误、人际关系和情绪。这不是一个普通的播客。这里的一切都是自发的、真实的、真诚的，只是关于活着意味着什么的诚实对话。我是Javier Tornandez，在IHard Radio、Apple Podcasts上收听《学习做人》，
or wherever you get your podcast. For years, the Un-House has been presented as a monolith in mainstream media. Wheatian House is a podcast that's changing the narrative. I'm Theo Henderson, and I created the show why I was Un-Housed on the streets of Los Angeles. We've grown into a two-time Webby Award-winning podcast, the only podcast that shares Un-House stories
或任何你获取播客的地方。多年来，无家可归者在主流媒体中一直被呈现为一个单一的群体。《Wheatian House》是一个正在改变这种叙事的播客。我是Theo Henderson，我在洛杉矶街头无家可归时创建了这个节目。我们已经成长为一个两次获得威比奖的播客，是唯一一个分享无家可归者故事……
and news from the Un-House perspective. Listen to Weythian House on the I-Hard Radio app, Apple Podcasts or wherever you get your podcast. Every family has its secrets. But what happens when you discover that your dad has been living a double life? That is not the look of an innocent man. Is everyone lying to me about who they are? I felt such desperation.
和来自无家可归者视角的新闻的播客。在I-Hard Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《Weythian House》。每个家庭都有秘密。但当你发现你的父亲一直过着双重生活时会发生什么？那看起来不像是一个无辜的人。每个人都在对我撒谎吗？我感到如此绝望。
I felt it was what I had to do. Listen to Deep Cover the Family Man. On the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast, guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我觉得这是我必须做的事。在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《Deep Cover: The Family Man》。这是一个IHeart播客，保证是人类制作的。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。